hi Matt Welch here with Nick Gillespie
we're here on ask a libertarian day in
honor of the publication the paperback
version of the Declaration of
Independence how libertarian politics
can fix what's wrong with America Nick
next question this one comes from Dana
Perino the former bush communications
officer who's now one of the co-hosts of
the five on Fox News a great show Dana
Perino
asks what's the simplest explanation
about the difference between
conservatives who say they're socially
liberal and fiscally conservative and
real libertarians Dana thanks for the
question we don't necessarily try to
define real libertarians but for me one
of the ways I look for posers is if they
say they're fiscally conservative but
they're not willing to put defense on
the table if they say they're socially
liberal but they're not willing to
actually put free speech you know really
a front and center then I tend to think
these people are just pretending to be
libertarians because libertarianism is
getting hot Dana asks a 5-part question
but willing to take part to a lot of
people in the queue here as they say in
England so as someone with evolving
views on the legalization of drugs Dana
Perino asks us could you describe what
the transition period would be like if
the USA were to legalize what would
happen to people currently serving
sentences for drug-related crimes great
question I think the first step is
legalization of recreational marijuana I
mean actually the first step has already
been taken in many ways where states
have been introducing medical marijuana
for people who can get a prescription
written for whatever use that they want
but I think we need to get to a point
where we're not locking up or not
arresting 800,000 people a year based on
a substance that the president is used
very vigorously and and everyone after a
certain age pretty much has used without
dying or hurting themselves it's
ridiculous it's an outrage
what happens to the people who are
currently in jail they'll be treated on
a case-by-case basis kind of like people
right now who have been sentenced for
crack sentences that have since been
reduced but I think the first ultimate
step is
to legalize the one substance that so
many people have used without damaging
themselves that has created a just an
abysmal situation in our criminal
justice system you know the great thing
about ending marijuana prohibition too
is that we have a template for this with
liquor prohibition and most of these
problems have been addressed in the past
and there were a lot of problems with
the end of prohibition but it serves as
a pretty good guideline ask a
libertarian we're here all day come on
back